I'm a huge Ronnie fan I really am Ronnie
I'm very open sexually but your sex tips
are the most disturbing audio since JD's
wedding vows people are giving you a lot
of [ __ ] about using Dean Cain's body for
those posters it was actually an even
trade I don't know if you know this Dean
Cain has been using your body as proof
that leprechauns exist Ronnie Ronnie
wants to open an animal hospital someday
Ronnie the 9/11 hijackers had a more
well-thought-out retirement no you'll be
great at it I love the idea of you with
an animal hospital some little kid
brings in their sick pet gerbil and you
immediately shove it up at your ass to
keep it warm
you pulled more things out of your ass
than Sal explaining the civil war
Ronni you do take your job very
seriously that's what I appreciate about
you you when you drive you treat Howard
like royalty
specifically Princess Diana 69 what's it
like to know that you're going to be out
lived by your fiance and most house
flies I just want to say before I go I
am a huge fan of the show and you and
your truly beloved Ronnie like you
really are and I know that even long
after Howard retires you're still going
to be able to draw a crowd with a crayon
in your assisted living facility